I'll talk about Bernie Sanders in a
little bit but very very soon after
Bernie's endorsement of 2020 Democratic
presidential nominee Joe Biden former
President Barack Obama has now endorsed
former VP Joe Biden there are people
saying Obama should have gotten involved
earlier I think it was pretty clear
Obama was never going to endorse Bernie
and in the end the guy Obama would
likely have endorsed one anyway so the
conversation about is Obama late seems
practically speaking irrelevant but
let's take a look - just a little bit of
Barack Obama's statement yesterday I
believe it was a 12 minute statement in
total we'll look about look at about a
minute and a half here I'm so proud to
endorse Joe Biden for President of the
United States
choosing Joe to be my vice president was
one of the best decisions I ever made
and he became a close friend and I
believe Joe has all the qualities we
need in a president right now he's
someone whose own life has taught him
how to persevere how to bounce back when
you've been knocked down when Joe talks
with parents who've lost their jobs we
hear the son of a man who once knew the
pain of having to tell his children that
he'd lost his when Joe talks about
opportunity for our kids we hear the
young father who took the train home
each night so he could tuck his children
into bed and we hear the influence of
Jill a lifelong teacher when Joe talks
to families who've lost a hero we hear
another parent of an American veteran a
kindred spirit somebody whose faith has
endured the hardest loss there is that's
Joe through all his trials he's never
once forgotten the values or the moral
fiber that his parents passed on to him
and that made him who he is
that's what steals his faith in God in
America and in all of us certainly
filled with lots of political speak that
to me it speaks to me very very little
it doesn't speak to me very strongly for
lack of a better term but Barack Obama's
involvement is potentially very
important here whatever you think about
Barack Obama or
Joe Biden a highly involved Barack Obama
improves the chances that Donald Trump
is defeated you might remember back in
2008 george w bush was very unpopular
and was almost completely missing from
the campaign trail in support of the
Republican nominee John McCain just
didn't make sense it was possibly going
to hurt John McCain to have George W
Bush heavily involved in the 2008
Republican campaign for the presidency
ultimately McCain lost anyway to Barack
Obama in this case it's very very
different if and when the the real
campaigning is able to get going and
this will depend on the virus of course
there may be a window there between you
know early July through late September
maybe before wave 2 is likely to hit
where there will be some real
campaigning I believe it's a very good
thing for Joe Biden for Barack Obama to
be right there with him and for better
or worse Obama there with Biden will
create the contrast in people's minds of
Trump versus what things were like under
Barack Obama now I want to be really
clear about what I mean by that Barack
Obama was wrong on many issues right the
Obama administration's dealing of with
whistleblowers was not good the Obama
administration's drone warfare policy
was not good we could go on and on but
the u.s. was respected as an adult was
leading us back then because we had an
adult leading us and with the country
shut down it's very difficult to gain
any momentum if you're Joe Biden Trump
is making bad decisions daily with
coronavirus but sadly many of his
followers seem to fall more and more in
love with Trump the worst his decisions
on coronavirus are some even see Trump
is decisive and strong and powerful in
the context of coronavirus so Biden
needs to do something to get attention
and start building momentum okay I guess
eventually there are going to be debates
we don't know exactly what the format
will be again because of the virus but
one way to maybe start building momentum
to a small degree would be to see Barack
Obama's increased involvement Barack
Obama of course much more powerful on
social media than Joe Biden and I've
said it before and
said it many times the choice is just
really clear and there are people on
Twitter talking about how do you choose
between two Nazis don't you just opt out
this is not a choice between two Nazis
this is a choice between a lunatic
authoritarian who is in way over his
head
cares only about himself and whose
decisions are leading to more
coronavirus deaths than were necessary
or than what the minimum could have
otherwise been that's one option the
other option is a center-left diplomat
with decades of experience who's less
progressive than I would like the
president to be the courts alone are
enough to show us the importance of
voting for Biden when you compare Biden
and Trump on the environment
Biden's way better when you compare
Biden and Trump on regulating business
Biden's better Biden's tax plan is
better Biden's health insurance plan is
better
Biden's better on LGBT rights Biden's
better on abortion and on and on and on
there's just no comparison I don't need
Joe to come beg for my vote I know that
there's a lot of Bernie supporters
saying Joe needs to come get my vote Joe
needs to put out a policy platform which
we can analyze like adults and make
decisions about I don't need to try to
get anybody's attention by claiming you
know I might stay home I might do it or
I might write in somebody else
it's not a blank check to the Democratic
Party I'm not even a Democrat it's that
I've looked at the policy platforms and
Biden's the clear better choice Biden
isn't entitled to anything the DNC is
not entitled to anything
I don't vote blue no matter who I'm not
a Democrat I'm looking at the candidates
it's clear which one is better that's
all this is now in the meantime a former
Republican congressman Justin Amash who
left the Republican Party and became an
independent Justin Amash is reportedly
thinking about running as an independent
this would be tremendously useful to Joe
Biden and potentially damaging to Donald
Trump Amash as a longtime Republican
would likely pull way more Republican
votes than he pulls Democratic votes and
being from Michigan which could end up
being a very important state in the 2020
November
Michigan's governor even being sort of
thrown around as a possible running mate
for Joe Biden it could be a absolutely
delightful thing and could
single-handedly hand Michigan to Joe
Biden just a rumor that Justin Amash is
thinking about that I say we encouraged
him to run I think it's a very very good
idea today's program is sponsored in
part by the galaxy Series which is a
series of three books written by a
really great author I thought and I
would call the genre sort of political
science fiction I've really enjoyed the
books it looks at the future it explores
what could happen to Planet Earth if we
stay on our path environmentally it
deals with space travel it takes a sort
of deep dive into political psychology
and it's a really intriguing sort of
dystopian look at the future the stories
are told from a perspective that I think
people in the audience would really
appreciate and there's a ton of really
excellent artwork also that accompanies
the books I read a lot of books in this
genre and I'll tell you these books are
very well written the plot the
characters are compelling if you're
someone who likes politics and sci-fi
you'll really like these books again
it's the galaxy series check it out for
yourself you can find it at david
pakman.com slash galaxy